bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est devant
chez business france pour parler de la
french stakes et les rencontres
internationales de la french state
business france aide les entreprises
technologiques et startups innovantes à
développer il ya une très très grosse
journée qui a été organisée aujourd'hui
pour parler fectivement des start up les
aider à développer et à se structurer
pour se développer à l'international
on regarde ça ensemble et vous allez
voir c'est super intéressant
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui on parle des
rencontres internationales de la
frenchie tête la quatrième édition alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en parle tout
simplement parce que c'est bien sûr une
chaîne youtube c'est qu'ils demandent
parler d'eux a été avec de présenter des
produits des produits qu'on connaît mais
ne veut pas oublier non plus les
startups françaises innovantes y en a
énormément il ya beaucoup de réussite ya
beaucoup de produits très sympa le bo de
sa couronne alors bonjour je m'appelle
michel brieu là je viens de limoges et à
vous présenter une nouvelle application
qui s'appelle li musique et c'est une
web application c'est en fait que ça
c'est une page web
on va retrouver son soleil sur votre
site voilà on se connecte sur le site
correspond décret amazon où on voit la
sncf d'accord en fait on va aller ouvrir
la page applications on va jouer
directement sur le sur la page web un
laïcat donc c'est un compagnon de vie
pour chien c'est un robot qui va
permettre d'interagir à distance avec
son chien donc tout simplement en fait
on prend le contrôle du robot avec son
téléphone sur lequel on a un retour
vidéo en direct
donc on va pouvoir se balader chez soi
et voir son chien mais on va aussi
pouvoir lui parler on pourra vous
prévenir quand lui aboie de manière
répétée on a aussi intégré un lanceur de
friandises données c'est à dire que donc
voilà ici là il ya le lanceur et donc on
à la trappe avec les réservoirs ici un
peu visé le chien si jamais y tomber
trop alors sa part pas trop fait
c'est quand même gros clous ses rentes
ai pas fait un petit un petit mètre mais
on va la sauver le chien non plus
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut lui demander
un second beau qu'est ce qui peut faire
qu'est-ce qui peut en fait
donc sarko qui va pouvoir des
applications pour les enfants les
parents les personnes âgées par exemple
il va pouvoir regarder la maison contre
n'est pas l'âge entendu dire que dis je
vais bosser garde la maison qui va se
mettre en mode veille basque j'étais si
un mouvement aussi à des bruits bizarres
si un incendie et envoyé une
notification sur le smartphone d'accord
et du coup à distance fait travailler
deux connectés et voir ce qui se passe
une loi d face robot à la maison pour
vérifier c'est pas un problème
cette possibilité de téléprésence on
appelle ça ça permet aussi du conte en
déplacement de pouvoir être avec des
gamins dans la chambre est joué
des applications dédiées au ludo
éducatifs pour les enfants de la manger
ma d'apprendre de colomb
1 2 3 soleil joue à cache cache avec un
petit rouleau et ensuite on a des
applications de l'âge de courant assez
pour la météo
passe-moi de la musique pour des
recettes de cuisine le genre de choses
l'accord doit donc c'est vraiment à 360
c'est vraiment sur la sécurité pour les
enfants pour la famille pour tous
vraiment content mais c'est vraiment
dans la famille mais maxime bonjour je
vois la maxime que j'avais rencontré à
l'ifa berlin si vous avez suivi et vidéo
et maxime qui travaille pour business
france et qui fait partie de la french
doctor est ce que là on est sur les
rencontres intéressantes dans leurs
pronostics 2017 est ce que tu peux nous
présenter très rapidement pour ne dire
voilà en quoi ça consiste et qu'est ce
qu'on peut y trouver les rencontres
internationales de la french tech c'est
le moment où tous les acteurs de
l'écosystème donc de la french tech vont
se rencontrer
donc ça peut être des start up c'est
peut être beaucoup de personnes de chez
business france puisque aujourd'hui il
ya quelques vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'experts de tous les pays que nous
représentons dans le monde
donc si vous avez envie de vous étendre
à l'international en afrique du sud au
brésil
c'est le moment où on rencontre
internationale a french tech
il y a aussi les la remise des prix des
trophées internationales du numérique ou
pitchent pas mal de start up et ça s'est
organisé en partenariat avec lui au club
d'accord on s'est quand même une journée
qui est consacrée à ces startups
innovantes et à tout l'écosystème
comment développer notre écosystème à
l'international si tu as envie de te
développer dans un pays c'est
aujourd'hui que tu peux rencontrer un
expert du pays quelqu'un qui vit là-bas
quelqu'un qui a pour mission de
t'accueillir dans ce pays là et de
t'expliquer la culture l'économie
comment communiquer là bas c'est très
différent la législation peut être
différente présentée dans les normands
deux pays
quels sont les pays où dans lesquelles
les entreprises françaises on rencontre
le plus de succès alors mon secteur
étant celui de la technologie est encore
plus de l'oeil aux ti et du hardware
évidemment le premier pays vers lequel
on se tourne en général qui sont les
états unis donc là on est avec noemi qui
est business france à new york
quelle est ta part
dans l'invention sein de business france
sur les états unis son développement des
entreprises technologiques alors aux
états unis donc business france opère
avec trois projets principaux le premier
ça va être la communication donc on
accompagne les entreprises françaises
dans les plus gros salon aux états unis
donc par exemple au cs ou nrf à south by
southwest ce genre de salon donc sous le
pavillon french tech
la deuxième offre ça va être
l'accélération avec le french tech tour
on va accompagner les entreprises sur
deux semaines donc c'est à la fois au
canada et aux etats unis san francisco
new york ou toronto montréal pour que
les entreprises donc commencé à sonder
le marché américain est le troisième pan
de notre offre c'est le problème
d'accélérations impact usa où là c'est
10 semaines d'immersion aux états unis à
san francisco ou à new york où les
entreprises ont pour but vraiment de
s'implanter dans la foulée du programme
et vont pouvoir commencer à tester
enfin plus que tester même à ce qu'elles
aient leur leur offre aux états unis
certes dix semaines pendant quelque
temps dans dix semaines elles vont être
présente mes genoux à san francisco et
elles vont pas de quelqu'un qui est un
produit innovant elle va faire quoi il
va essayer de trouver des distributeurs
elle va
aller prospecter pour propager la
profession produits en be to be des
choses comme ça de plus en plus amérique
du sud je pensais au brésil la vie me
paraît incontournable en tout cas c'est
des demandes très forte que nous avons
partir à singapour partira en conquérant
chine ne serait ce que pour
industrialiser ton produit et beaucoup
de personnes viennent en chine pour
mettre un pied et trouver des
industriels avec qui il travaillera plus
tard n'est évidemment disponible tout au
long de l'année vous pouvez inviter à
nous contacter dans un premier temps pas
hésité à venir nous voir parce que nous
sommes présents sur un grand nombre de
salles en grand nombre d'événements à
l'étranger donc si ça vous intéresse
contactez kevin parce qu'on joue mais un
lien dans la description
merci maxime merci à toi on va boire un
coup maintenant
[Musique]
erwan chapelier ce que pouvait
m'expliquer en quoi est-ce que l'inpi
aide les créateurs et les jeunes
startups à se développer une vie c'est
le temps comme la propriété
intellectuelle c'est là que nature
déposer des brevets et des marques
dessins et modèles
typiquement l'innovation verrière et des
investissements de r&d un moment donné
pour les cavs et par
une démarche qui va permettre de
sécuriser ses investissements de
l'arrivée quand on parle de solutions
technologiques sur le brevet de quoi ce
type de solutions il s'agit
d'investissements marketing ça te met
des marques l'inpi s'étant rendu compte
que beaucoup d'entrepreneurs oublier ce
sujet là en quête de l'or
projet
créateur pour justement dessiner les
stratégies propres idées pression colle
avec la stratégie de piste est d'accord
et c'est absolument important à faire
parce qu'il n'y a pas de stratégie de
business sans stratégie propriété
intellectuelle
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la lumière vidéo french tech
pour pouvoir enregistrer une annonce
pour dire ce qu'on ferait une annonce
pour dire de quoi on a besoin et tout ça
va être agrégées sur la lumière
vidéoprotection belle-fille business
pour faire en sorte que tous ne puisse
savoir qui fait quoi
[Musique]
k
voilà un peu tout ce qu'on peut lire
aujourd'hui sur les rencontres personnes
de leur tristesse
si vous êtes si vous avez une start-up
si vous vous avez un projet de starter
de création d'entreprises innovantes
technologique ou pas d'ailleurs business
france peut vous accompagner en tout cas
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo pour
moi c'était vraiment un grand grand
grand grand plaisir de pouvoir
rencontrer tous ces entrepreneurs toutes
ses équipes dédiées équipes de business
france la frenchie nike enfin ces voix
là toujours un très grand plaisir je
donne rendez vous très bientôt pour
d'autres vidéos on va continuer à parler
bien sûr de technologie on parlera de
technologies innovantes françaises de
plein d'autres techno des tutos des
choses voilà plein plein plein de choses
de tous les côtés
restez connectés si vous n'êtes pas
encore abonné à la chaîne je vous invite
à vous abonner pas se voir toujours plus
de contenus exclusifs
et puis mettez moi tout en commentaires
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
qu'il ya des choses qui vous ont plus
intéressés que d'autres ce que vous avez
été surpris
vous marquez tout ça et on en parle
ensemble quant à moi je vous dis au
revoir et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]